we now come to the leader of the SNP
Stephen Flynn
Mr Mr Speaker in 2010 David Cameron
convinced Nick Clegg to drop his Pledge
on University tuition fees does the
Prime Minister intend to take the credit
for convincing the leader of the labor
party to do likewise
[Applause]
well I I Thank The Honorable gentleman
for the question
it I'd say it's it's hard to keep up Mr
Speaker with a list of broken promises
but I would say or on tuition fees is
I'm proud that under this government we
now have a record number of people that
are going to University from
disadvantaged backgrounds Mr Speaker and
that's because the efforts we've paid to
put more money into supporting those
people and those communities fulfill
their aspirations alongside fantastic
new apprenticeships in every part of our
country
Mr Speaker for the avoidance of any
doubt the liberal Democrats don't
believe in abolishing tuition fees the
conservatives don't believe in
abolishing tuition fees and of course
the labor party now with their own Nick
leg moment don't believe in abolishing
it tuition fees ilor but Mr Speaker is
it is it not the case that the main
Westminster parties don't offer Young
offer young people any hope at all do
they
I actually actually I gently point out
to The Honorable gentleman that if
you're from a disadvantaged background
you're far more likely to go to
university in England than you are in
Scotland